here's what would happen if you lived in
a cosmic skyscraper your Penthouse would
be over 100 times higher than the
world's tallest building Dubai's 830
meter high Burj Khalifa to build up
you'd actually need lots of land an 8.8
kilometer tall building would need a 4
100 square kilometer base it would be so
heavy it would create a ditch in the
Earth's crust and dealing with the
gravitational forces would require heavy
duty building materials maybe a
high-tech form of carbon similar to
Diamond
that'll cost you a few trillion but the
high life isn't always so sweet you'd
see temperatures as low as minus 120
degrees and as high as a scorching 2 000
degrees if you wanted to take in those
balcony views you'd need to keep your
spacesuit on so